when it comes to the villains of the
handmaid's tale aunt lydia is among the
worst charged with training and
disciplining handmaids lydia has enraged
and disturbed fans since the show's
first season this is her story from her
time as a teacher to her future in
gilead
in season three we're introduced to a
pre-gilead lydia clements played by anne
dowd as it turns out aunt lydia was once
an elementary school teacher with a
background in family law this lydia wore
her hair down and was once married even
in this era however lydia was pretty
judgmental especially when it came to
religion and parenting this is explored
in flashbacks which see lydia befriend a
young single mother named noel and her
son ryan the trio grow close and even
spend christmas together lydia seems to
revel in being called aunt lydia by ryan
however she frowns on what she sees as
some poor parenting choices by noel
speaking to vanity fair after the
episode dowd said i think she at that
point in her life really wants to help i
think she probably got out of family law
because it was too painful to see the
separation to see the loss the only
other time lydia alluded to her past was
during season 2's smart power after june
asks her to protect her unborn baby
i was godmother to my sister's child
he died when he was four days old
soon after noelle gives lydia a makeup
set for christmas lydia goes on a date
with jim the principal of the school
where she works but after they begin
kissing jim suddenly wants to stop while
he likes her jim thinks they're rushing
things instead of understanding lydia
flies into a rage then catches a glimpse
of herself with makeup running down her
face lydia's emotions here are complex
as ann dowd explained to vanity fair i
was raised in a strong catholic home you
know sex is a very very tricky area and
there's a lot of guilt and a lot of
shame associated with it i think what i
loved about that moment is it said so
much about how she was raised and that
honestly shame is in charge of her life
lydia's shame quickly turns to revenge
after blaming noel for convincing her to
go on the date she does everything in
her power to separate noel from her son
after noel angrily confronts lydia jim
walks often disgust after seeing lydia's
true colors she justifies her actions by
telling herself that ryan is better off
without noel
aunt lydia uses fear abuse and religious
manipulation to train handmaids to give
up their bodily autonomy for the sake of
gilead according to lydia the handmaid's
horrific lives are divinely ordained and
thus beyond human doubt flashbacks to
the red center see lydia training one of
the first groups of handmaids including
june moira and janine she is immediately
set up as a villain who uses torture to
get the handmaids to comply for example
she doesn't think twice about removing
janine's eye when janine resists
becoming a handmaid after the handmaids
are placed in homes lydia also serves as
a liaison between the government of
gilead and individual households she
frequently makes house calls to ensure
that everyone is following the rules in
the first season we see her make a
handful of visits to the waterford
residence where june has been placed
lydia frequently asserts her power over
june and at one point even beats her
with a cattle prod before the
commander's wife serena joy stops her
lydia is responsible for devising many
of gilead's abusive training techniques
which include ordering handmaids to hold
rocks for hours in the rain getting them
to kill traitors with their bare hands
and making them believe they're about to
be hanged she also orchestrates most of
the physical mutilation that occurs
including removing janine's eye and
performing female circumcision on emily
when she isn't violently disciplining
handmaids lydia is the ultimate
gaslighter she twists women
psychologically in a variety of ways
including victim blaming and setting the
handmaids against each other lydia is
particularly abusive towards june and is
quick to shame her into believing that
her choices are what bring harm and
death to others it's all done in a bid
to keep june compliant which works but
only for a while
lydia refers to the handmaids as her
girls in fact lydia often paints herself
as the handmaid's protector and is quick
to blame herself when they fail in her
own twisted way she believes she really
does care about them as dowd explained
in 2017 at the core of her choices she
loves these girls deeply and wants them
to succeed in this new world and she is
keenly aware that if she doesn't get
them to get the drill immediately they
are not going to make it this twisted
motherliness is apparent when serena
tells aunt lydia to remove janine from
an important dinner because of her
missing eye then lydia seems to
sympathize with jeanine but later she
proves her loyalty to gilead by ordering
the other handmaids to stone janine to
death the handmaids led by june refuse
rather than let the guards shoot them
for their disobedience lydia asks them
to spare the handmaids these girls are
my responsibility in season two it is
revealed that lydia sent janine to the
colonies and punished the handmaids with
a mock execution
emily suffers greatly at lydia's hands
after discovering that emily is in a
romantic relationship with a martha
lydia has emily's lover murdered and
emily mutilated when emily seeks revenge
by killing a guardian lydia has her sent
to the colonies she eventually brings
emily back because they're short on
handmaids and pairs her with commander
lawrence finally in the season 2 finale
emily stabs lydia in the back while
lydia survives the event changes her
making her an even harder character show
creator bruce miller explained the
impact emily had on lydia telling forbes
she thinks there's love between her and
her girls the fact that one of her girls
has literally stabbed her in the back i
think that alters your workplace
feelings on a day-to-day basis i think
in her case it makes her double down she
feels like she just wasn't strong enough
in her discipline so she has decided
it's time to get tough after emily's
escape from gilead at the end of season
two lydia can't take her feelings out on
her instead lydia comes down even harder
on the remaining handmaids eventually
she snaps after janine begs to return to
her former family and her infant
daughter lydia beats her mercilessly in
front of a crowd only stopping when june
comes between them
the relationship between lydia and june
is rough from the start after an
antagonistic first season they seem to
grow closer in season two as a pregnant
june leans into lydia seeking protection
for her unborn baby during this time
period we learn that lydia has some
power over the commanders and their
wives as well since she is tasked with
evaluating whether the household is a
good fit for a child the short-lived
peace between june and lydia doesn't
last however when june orchestrates her
daughter nicole's escape lydia comes
down hard on her she forces june to
participate in propaganda videos with
waterfords and even accompanies the
family on a trip to washington while
there she seems disturbed by the sight
of handmaids whose mouths have been sewn
shut lydia is very much aware that jun's
biggest weakness is her daughter hannah
who was kidnapped by gilead when june's
family tried to escape in season three
after june tracks down hannah lydia
orders the execution of the martha who
helped june connect with her daughter as
if that wasn't enough lydia forces june
and the other handmaids to be the ones
to execute her
after june helps a plane load of gilead
children flee to canada in the season 3
finale lydia comes under fire as a
result lydia makes it her mission in
season 4 to find and reform june
according to miller lydia in this season
is in a position where she's just
obsessed with june and has so much of
her personal worth tied up in what june
is doing as the season progresses lydia
and june continue to circle one another
although lydia never manages to keep
june within her clutches for long but
even when they're apart they each
continue to occupy a significant portion
of the other's thoughts miller explained
although june and lydia are kind of
enemies in this story they are
inextricably linked they spend a ton of
time thinking about the other one and
what the other one is doing so it's
fascinating to have two people who
really would like to be both rid of each
other but who are tangled up with each
other all the time
after june escapes yet again in season 4
aunt lydia is no longer in gilead's good
graces for the first time we see lydia's
sparse living quarters after being
stripped of her responsibilities she's
expected to spend the rest of her days
doing puzzles and playing cards with her
fellow aunts however lydia wants her
power back and is not interested in
being forced into an early retirement so
lydia strikes a deal with commander
lawrence she'll give him dirt on his
fellow commanders if he'll restore her
to her former station she also wants to
be the one to punish june if and when
she is finally caught
after lydia regains her power it's
evident that she is still haunted by her
failure with june after learning that
june escaped to canada she quickly
spirals out of control in episode 8 she
takes out her frustrations on one of her
charges and then even turns on a fellow
aunt speaking to elle dowd said she
holds herself responsible so do the
commanders she knew something was
happening she knew it and she did not
follow it to its core and june whom she
has a tremendously complicated
relationship with pulled it off so
there's that personal factor where she's
being tough on herself because she knows
all of that and also desperate to prove
that no no no i'm not irrelevant
after losing june lydia gets a second
chance to reform janine after janine is
recaptured in chicago following lydia's
outburst commander lawrence tells her to
take her anger out on janine whose life
is now considered expendable in a rare
moment of weakness lydia reunites with
janine and actually heeds her request
not to be assigned to another commander
instead lydia decides to keep janine at
the center at first the other ants
question why lydia isn't doing god's
work and putting janine back into the
field but lydia finds a use for her
before long when the former mrs keys
reappears as the handmade esther the
traumatized girl mounts a hunger strike
that none of the ants can stop aunt
lydia agrees to let janine talk to her
and janine is able to convince esther to
comply warning her that if she doesn't
the consequences will be worse than
death janine's assistance earns aunt
lydia's trust and helps re-establish
lydia's power among the other ants
while lydia's future within the world of
hulu's the handmaid's tale remains
unwritten margaret atwood took matters
into her own hands with her 2019 novel
the testament a sequel to her original
novel the testaments is written from
three perspectives including aunt
lydia's it takes place 15 years after
the events of the first novel which were
covered in the first season of the show
in this sequel atwood reveals that in
the early days of gilead lydia was
rounded up with many other women she was
detained tortured and eventually given a
choice cooperate or face the
consequences lydia sees herself as
someone who did what she had to do in
order to survive eventually in the book
she becomes integral to the fall of
gilead how much this novel will affect
the future of the show remains to be
seen atwood's lydia is a very different
character in many respects in the book
lydia was a judge prior to gilead and
acts as a mole for the rebellious
organization mayday for now one thing is
sure aunt lydia will definitely go down
as one of the most compelling tv
villains of all time check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff for coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you